le président des sénateurs socialistes
et d'invités de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir didier guillemin au soir michel
grossiord merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec les
échos radio classique et l' agence
france-presse
et vous répondrai dans les 45 minutes
qui suivent à trois grandes questions
d'abord françois fillon et il en fait
votre meilleur adversaire vous le dirai
à jean francis pécresse qui ont ensuite
françois hollande manuel valls qui est
le mieux placé selon vous pour 2017 la
rivalité au sommet de l'exécutif ait
existé bien sûr abordé tout à l'heure
par stéphanie le rouge
enfin le sénat est il devenu selon vous
depuis quelques temps le laboratoire du
fioul nisme questions posées tout à
l'heure par michael à metz mais d'abord
une première question d'actualité
on le sait avec les journalistes
françois hollande est il aussi
inconscient en mettant à leur
disposition des documents classés
confidentiel défense
non non mais ça c'est une supercherie
c'est un montage fait par la droite les
élus de droite notamment monsieur ciotti
qui depuis dimanche soir a beaucoup de
temps pour s'occuper de la destitution
du président de la république non
réalité publié par a été publiée voilà
ce n'est pas du tout ce n'est pas du
tout un problème du président de la
république il a dit ensemble de choses
tout le monde savait qu'il y avait des
missions en syrie tout le monde le
savait rien n'a été dévoilé donc voilà
c'est je pense que c'est un écran de
fumée pour faire oublier autre chose
c'est dommage je vais vous dire une
chose quand on passe son temps à
dénigrer le président de la république
on dénigre la france quand j'entends
monsieur goasguen qui ce matin dit
holland dégage c'est pas la hauteur du
débat politique faut pas s'étonner après
si tous les populismes
si tous les extrémismes règne en maître
dans ce pays parce que le président de
la république qui a été élu
il a été élu par tous les français nous
sommes en fin de quinquennat et jusqu'au
mois de mai et les présidents de la
république il faut respecter la fonction
l'homme parce que nous respectons la
république et nous respectons la prend
là on parle de révélations qui font
l'objet
didier guillaume d'une enquête ouverte
fabrice ars et aux dirigeants c'est
d'être obligé à partir moi on me demande
a été faite par des députés
les républicains d'ailleurs au départ il
avait annoncé que c'est tout le groupe
finalement il n'a beaucoup moins et
aussi des gens qui réfléchissent salon
joue pas comme cela
on sait très bien que cette destitution
ne peut pas exister ne peut pas arriver
c'est un coup politique mais à force de
faire des coups politiques on s'aperçoit
que les électeurs de la primaire n'ont
fait un autre nom mais vous vous êtes
rassurés en quelque sorte on ira
jusqu'au bout de son mandat arriver sur
coupet attendra les sûr évidemment bien
mais quand même vous dit tout le monde
savait évidemment que la france voulait
intervenir en syrie mais de là à laisser
publier des documents sur une offensive
qui était prévu donc c'était en 2013
il n'y a pas que l'offensive qui avait
été faite il n'y a pas de révélations
dans cette danse et à faire d'ailleurs
c'était un plan oui d'ailleurs aucun nom
mais donner aucun lieu n'est donnée
simplement pour un dîner du républicain
et s'indigne de beaucoup de choses vous
dire une chose riche beau sûr qu'en
réalité 2 millions de français devant
leur télévision quand en direct de la
war room barraco il sut et barack obama
cherchant à dézinguer ben laden donc
faut arrêter cinéma tout ça aujourd'hui
chercher de devantures elle qui n'en
sont pas moi je refuse de commenter les
polémiques
aujourd'hui on a mieux à faire de
polémique et nous agirons pays
la droite est dans sa primaire chacun
doit faire ce qu'il a à faire mais de là
à montrer toujours du doigt le même je
trouve ça fait un coup quand vous nous
dites france hollande est un président
sans reproche un dans cette affaire là
un oui dans cet art là quand même que
jean marc ayrault avait dit à propos de
la révélation des opérations
d'assassinats ciblés à des terroristes à
l'étranger avec un effectif n'a rien à
voir là non ça n'a rien à voir mais on
était quand même dans le domaine
militaire domaine du confidentiel
secret défense et jean marc ayrault
avait dit effectivement un président
devrait se taire je ne sais pas ce qu'il
est déjà remarqué route 6 arrêts mais
moi ça ne m'intéresse pas ce que je sais
c'est que le président travaille et que
ce que je sais ce clan que nous sommes
en guerre et ben il est des faits de
guerre voilà vous d'accord alors votre
défense était effectivement vive assurer
des chars est ce que vous ne craignez
pas quand même pour lui un nouvel effet
d'image
ah mais ça vous savez aujourd'hui je ne
suis ni sourd ni aveugle je vois ce que
disent les français et ce que disent y
compris les zus que 10 des femmes et des
hommes de gauche
je vois bien qu'il ya encore du travail
d'ici la fin du quinquennat il va
falloir le faire bien c'est dur parfois
d'être toujours assuré la défense tout
azimut la dune chef de l'état vient
guillaume s'est jamais dur non parce que
vous savez lorsqu'on est parlementaire
de la république française
rien n'est dur par rapport à ce que je
vois pour mes enfants
par rapport à ce que je vois par adam là
dans la population rien n'est dur ce qui
est dur c'est d'être au chômage
ce qui est dur c'est de vivre dans la
précarité faire de la politique
lorsqu'on est passionné comme moi
lorsqu'on aime cela lorsqu'on aime peut
batailler dans le respect des gens et
des autres jamais un mot plus haut que
l'autre vis-à-vis des personnes n'est
pas dur d'être toujours un rôle d'avocat
on n'est pas du tout au contraire 1 face
à tous les procureurs
c'est un bonheur de faire un mouroir de
faire ce travail côté jour proposé après
la défense je vous propose la tac avec
la première partie de l'épreuve de
vérité pour laquelle donc nous
accueillons jean-francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
pensez sans michel bonsoir didier
quillot bonsoir alors est ce que
françois fillon est votre meilleur
adversaire ce dans l'hypothèse bien sûr
où il serait confirmée dimanche prochain
lors de la primaire à droite
quelle surprise quelle surprise pour les
sondeurs quelle surprise pour les
journalistes
quelle surprise pour les responsables
politiques on voyait bien que françois
fillon remonter mais personne de penser
y compris peut-être lui-même y compris
c'est plus proche qu'il arriverait à 44%
qu'il arriverait à ce niveau là nous
n'avons pas à choisir nos adversaires
pour la pour l'élection présidentielle
ce n'est pas notre problème
d'ailleurs moi j'ai regretté que des
femmes et des hommes de gauche sont
allés voter il fallait pour une chose et
il faut nous préserver d'un retour de
sarkozy bon je crois que les choses ont
été faites maintenant au deuxième tour
c'est la droite qui va choisir si c'est
françois fillon françois fillon pour la
première fois dans la vème république la
droite aura lui un candidat très à
droite le plus à droite de la vème
république
est ce que ça veut dire que vous appeler
clairement les sympathisants de gauche
ce soir à ne pas aller voter alain juppé
dimanche prochain à la main droite
moi je n'ai pas appelé les gens sont
libres mais je ne vous leur demandez en
tout cas non mais je ne comprends pas
que lorsque l'on est de gauche on aille
voter à la primaire de la droite donc il
me semble que lorsqu'on est de gauche on
ne se déplace pas des manches peu
importe que ce soit alain juppé ou
françois fillon c'est le choix de la
droite de même que lorsque nous nous
serons dans notre primaire j'espère que
je souhaite que femme je souhaite que
les femmes et les hommes de droite ne
viennent pas voter aux primaires parce
que c'est le choix d'un camp politique
est ce que c'est parce que au fond de
vous-même vous espérez bien avoir
françois fillon candidat de la droite
le 28 n'arme écoutez moi je moi je ne me
place pas dans ce set la d'esprit à une
semaine ou dix jours personnes pensent
et françois fillon serait au deuxième
tour et on disait mais vous préférez
alain juppé ont nicolas sarkozy et déjà
je répondais je répondais peu importe la
forme
je vous ai dit s'il est élu ce sera le
candidat le plus à droite ab oui le
candidat le plus à droite samsonov
avantage françois fillon c'est le
candidat de plus à droite quand on
regarde le programme aujourd'hui de la
droite entre alain juppé et françois
fillon globalement il ya les mêmes
choses globalement les mêmes choses on
supprime ensuite primes des
fonctionnaires on supprime les
fonctionnaires aussi des fonctions et
fonctionne actionnaires 300 mille cinq
cent mille postes de fonctionnaires des
postes de fonctionnaires mais rendez
vous quand ken que supprimer 500 mille
postes de fonctionnaires ça veut dire
qu'on recrute plus d'un de questions
nationales dans la police et dans la
justice dans la gendarmerie
c'est aberrant comme le dit alain juppé
mais bien sûr bien sûr on a eu plusieurs
écrits mais de postes de fonctionnaires
comment il ne faut plus en supprimer
vous ne soutenez pas d'ailleurs vous
même nom sur le quinquennat depuis le
début 2012
vous avez fait plus 30000 évolutionnaire
de l'état oui est ce que vous êtes
content de ce bilan par exemple non je
ne suis pas content du bilan j'en suis
très fier très fier et je le revendique
comme boire des cas et hommes de gauche
d'avoir rendez vous dire pourquoi
j'aimerais nouveau poste je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que quand nous
créant 60000 postes dans l'éducation
nationale
car caen depuis 2012 il n'y a pas une
fermeture de classe unique en zone
rurale car depuis 2012 nous mettons des
moyens dans les zones quand la droite
quand la droite supprime huit ou neuf
mille postes de policiers nous nous en
créons 13000 et je suis fier de cela
lorsque français parce que la france a
besoin de fonctionnaires pour la police
l'a justement n'a jamais manqué lorsque
derrière ogier sur ce moment qu'on ne
manque pas de dire aux policiers en
policiers on est honnêtes au dépôt rubis
de 58% et l'allemagne qui a moins de
moins de fonctionnaires qui n'est pas
réputé pour être un pays à la traîne à
44 % de dépenses prix mais vous savez 14
points d'écart de 2,2 une bible vous
savez très bien qu'on ne peut pas le
faire avant aux gens encore que on
manque de fonctionnaires en france au
tournant mais je n'ai pas des sages la
dépense publique pour la fonction
publique augmente de 700 millions
d'euros par an 700 millions d'euros par
an si je peux me permettre
comment est-ce qu'on finance à françois
fillon se blesser répandre j'aurais
rendrai en si vous laissez pas répondre
je n'aurais pas dit par exemple que nous
nous endettons chaque année pour
rémunérer ses fastes des fonctionnaires
fo c'est faux c'est faux c'est faux
alors
on pourra parler de l'allemagne excusez
moi de vous dire vous êtes trop affûté
pour penser que cette comparaison ne
vaut rien
pourquoi un nouveau rien votre
comparaison avec l'allemagne parce que
vous parlez de l'état fédéral et pas des
länder et si vous rajoutez l'état
fédéral et les länder
je connais bien l'allemagne je suis
germanophile on sait très bien qu'il ya
des fonctionnaires dans les länder
vous vous ne prenez que l'état fédéral
nouilles en compte pas les régions
encore mais sûre si on ne compte qu'un
petit bol nationale joue notre objectif
notre nom mais oui mais non pas du tout
l'allemagne ne peut pas faire cette
comparaison
mais nous notre objectif ce n'est pas de
créer des fonctionnaires je peux vous
dire qu'un que de grégory sert d'en
avoir je suis très fier d'avoir créé ce
sont 1000 postes dans la dans
l'éducation nationale
je suis très fier qu'on a un bilan de +
13 mille postes dans les forces de
sécurité la justice parce que ça c'est
la régate et renaud jean les gens nous
le demande ça mais nous nous sommes
arrivés avec des déficits
nous étions à 5 % de d2d mais si nous
allons être à 3%
monsieur fillon bis faut passer à 4,2
nom et du service à sa 4e oui mais
peut-être mais quand on regarde le bilan
de ce quinquennat sur tout un tas de
sujets et notamment sur la dette ce qui
aurait augmenté la dette de 600
milliards d'euros 600 milliards je sais
pas si vous rendez compte que c'est
pendant le quinquennat précédent alors
que nous nous lavons diminué on ne fait
pas des leçons à la gestion en revient
aux programmes de français il est quoi
françois fillon il est sept chez rien
pour vous il est très saine chez rien il
est libéral économiquement et
conservateurs socialement c'est vraiment
ce qui le caractérise le plus possible
je rappelle quand même le bilan demande
à mme thatcher toute la dérégulation
notamment dans les transports
ferroviaires françois fillon il veut
baisser l'impôt sur le revenu pour les
familles aisées
nous ne baissons pour 12 millions de
foyers fiscaux pour les familles
classement classe moyenne il veut
supprimer l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune
on voit quand même c'est qu'il est très
libéral il veut augmenter la tva rendez
vous compte de
pour cent voire des camps ça veut dire
qu'une simple de deux points ça veut
dire que tous les français lorsqu'ils
vont acheter leurs produits de première
nécessité vont être impactés par une
augmentation
nous nous sommes refusés à le à le faire
on a parlé des fonctionnaires il était
on a parlé on a parlé de la tva sociale
nous pensons nous que c'est une que
paris est en baisse les cotisations que
c'est une
et puis sur l'aspect international il
aura à répondre à des questions et sur
la société sur la famille j'ai compris
d'ailleurs depuis ce matin et a entendu
monsieur raffarin entendu monsieur juppé
lui-même que dans le débat et dans les
meetings on va avoir des questions sur
la famille sur les questions sociétales
et sur l'international puisque sur
l'international ça peut être un
renversement d'alliance et un changement
de pied par rapport notamment à la
russie de monsieur poutine
et là il faudra qu'il s'explique merci
beaucoup merci jean francis deuxième
partie de l'épreuve de vérité avec
stéphanie le rouge de l' agence france
presse qui nous rejoint
l'épreuve de vérité avec l'iphone
bonsoir stéphanie et merci d'être avec
nous votre question président des
sénateurs ps ici au sénat oui alors nous
souhaitons savoir si pour vous françois
hollande est le meilleur candidat ou
peut-être manuel valls puisque celui ci
est depuis en plus à l'offensive
françois hollande et manuel valls sont
les deux meilleurs candidats
nous pouvons avoir donc pour moi les
choses sont très claires il n'y a pas à
les opposer
il n'y a pas posé ces questions le
président de la république a dit qu'il
donnerait sa réponse le 10 décembre
s'il est candidat je le soutiendrai pas
ce qu'il est capable de porter le bilan
de son quinquennat qui a été décrit tout
au long de ce quinquennat
à gauche comme à droite d'ailleurs parce
que les fraudeurs ne nous ont pas aidés
mais dans ce quinquennat sera
revalorisée j'en suis j'en suis certain
s'il est candidat je le soutiendrai
et s'il n'est pas candidat eh bien je
pense que c'est manuel valls qui est
celui qui devra prendre le flambeau
parce qu'il a été ministre pendant cinq
ans et là il a été premier ministre
depuis 2014
mais moi je ne veux pas participer au
débat de choisir l'un ou l'autre parce
qu'en fait institutionnellement la
question ne va pas se poser
ils n'ont pas être candidats l'un contre
l'autre ou l'un face à l'autre ou l'un à
côté de l'autre ce sont les institutions
une fois que le président de la
république qui aura fait son choix sa
position dans la vème république
eh bien les choses se décanteront et
enfants vous pensez que sa position
actuelle
quelle est elle je ne sais pas quoi
attendre trois semaines que c'est un peu
lent non mais dans mes trois semaines
dont l'entourage on en est à se dire
trouve que ça suffit cette course de
lenteur
mais c'est pas une course de lenteur il
a fixé le calendrier j'avais dit je
crois chez vous d'ailleurs que ici même
à public sénat que le président de la
république est le maître de l'horloge
attentivement il a dit qu'il donnerait
sa réponse mais avant la mi décembre
donnera sa réponse à voir la mi décembre
maintenant jean marie le guen que manuel
valls se doit se tenir prêt non non non
justement c'est ce que j'allais vous
dire votre question tombe bien j'ai dire
qu'une nous nous devons nous tenir prêts
parce qu'il ne suffit pas d'attendre
comme ça comme les uns oracle la
position d'intel d'intel qu'est ce qui
se passe le jour où il se déclare que
faisons nous commençons nous et la
stratégie des socialistes de ceux qui
soutiennent le président de la
république de ce qu'ils sont ce qu'on
appelle la gauche de la réforme la
gauche de gouvernement les sociaux
démocrates
c'est de préparer la primaire dès la
gauche lurons qui aura lieu le 22 et le
29 janvier c'est ça notre et si tous les
socialistes la d'entre aujourd'hui
maintenant à l'heure où on parle et le
dise ou de 15 décembre se met à
travailler sur le fond sur
l'organisation l'archictecture de telle
ou telle candidature je pense que les
choses avanceront mieux alors nous ne
restons pas larmes au pied et ne ne
cherchant pas opposés l'un à l'autre ça
n'a aucun sens ils ne peuvent pas être
opposés parce qu'ils ne sont ni
concurrents ni adversaire alors qu'ils
sont tous les deux des normes d'énormes
qualités
le président de la réveiller une place
pour deux ans et il n'y a qu'une place
est à l'arrivée
donc le président de la khl il donnera
sa sa réponse il est candidat ce sera
lui vous pensez que manuel valls a peu
joué le rôle de rassembleur de la gauche
parce qu'il a quand même l'image de
quelqu'un d'extrêmement clients il
n'avait fait que 5 % à la primaire de
il reste identifié à la droite du ps
quand même non mais c'est le premier
ministre de la france
il est comptable du quinquennat
puisqu'il a été pendant cinq ans
au gouvernement qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pendant ces 4 c 5 ans pourquoi je
vous dis que ce bilan va être
revalorisée j'ai mis sur mon papier 5,6
points les inégalités elles ont baissé
les finances ont été redressés
l'économie a été à redémarrer notre
modèle social a été préservé la sécurité
sociale est équilibré et l'école est
devenue la pole la priorité voilà c'est
laid ce sont les orientations de gauche
si là dessus ce gouvernement des
millions de personnes dans l'offre du
million avec le travail
si on cumule les très nombreuses alors
dans ces cas là si vous voulez avoir le
record du monde vous ajouter ceux qui
ont été mis dans la rue par alain juppé
par françois fillon
mais là c'est des dizaines de millions
de personnes sur la durée de verdure de
records donc je me vois pas les records
de mai on attend le chiffre aujourd'hui
la courbe du chômage s'est inversée
aujourd'hui il y a plus de demain de
deux demandeurs d'emploi qu'il n'y en
avait en 2012 parce qu'il y a plus de
gens sur le marché qui n'en avaient en
aujourd'hui lille c'est l'insee le dit
très bien
le chômage a baissé pour la première
fois depuis des années 90
autant mais moi je n'aime pas parler de
cela parce que en fait on est le choix
c'est pas tellement dans le bilan mais
chômage celui-ci mais je peux vous les
pourquoi parce que moi ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont les femmes et des
hommes c'est la pâte humaine quand ils
chômage baisse de 65 mille îles a baissé
sur l'année il aura baisser le chômage
aura baissé sur l'année nous avons gagné
notre pari
mais c'est rien par rapport à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui sont demandeurs
d'emploi qui sont au chômage qui
souffrent est-ce que emmanuel macron
pour vous va être celui qui va enterrer
la gauche du fait de ses divisions
mais si emmanuel macron continue ce
choix solitaire va jusqu'au bout comme
il a dit vous savez l'élection
présidentielle c'est encore très loin
mais si il dépose sa candidature avec
les 500 parrainages
ça veut dire qu'il fait le choix de la
victoire de la droite en presque ils
devraient discuter avec nous jean
christophe cambadélis
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste lui a dit emmanuel vient
dans la primaire de la gauche qu'il
vienne dans cette primaire il se dit je
suis ni de droite ni de gauche
faire comme conclusion à la primaire de
la droite que les partis politiques sont
morts au moment où les républicains à
organiser une primaire de plus de 4
millions de personnes
excusez moi de vous dire que c'est un
peu hardie comme raisonnement le clivage
droite gauche vous vous estimez qu'il
était écouté on apprend réalisé dans la
première partie dans la première partie
de l'émission de reparler du programme
de françois fillon
ceux qui pensent qu'il n'ya pas de
différence entre la droite et la gauche
se mette le doigt dans l'oeil
oui je vais vous demander entre françois
hollande et manuel valls
est ce que l'un pour vous est mieux
placé que l'autre pour empêcher une
éventuelle candidature de maquereaux non
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas non mais
il n'y a pas d'argument ses défauts la
politique il faut pas faire de la petite
politique aguerri et des trucs de
boutiques ça ne marche pas faut
s'adresser aux françaises et aux
français au peuple pour l'instant
emmanuel macron est sur son nuage il a
fait des marches il a fait du
porte-à-porte il est candidat
très bien il faut que celles et ceux qui
le soutiennent se rendent compte qu'il
n'a pas il ne peut pas arriver au bout
il n'a pas d' espace politique
il y aura une droite peut-être un
candidat du centre et un candidat
socialiste et d'extrême gauche et
d'extreme droite emmanuel macron ne veut
pas être en l'air en lévitation tout le
temps moi je regrette emmanuel macron
doit faire partie de notre dispositif
il a travaillé à l'elysée sous
l'autorité du président de la république
pendant des années il a été ministre a
pas été facile toujours défendre la loi
macron moi je les défends du jour que
jusqu'au bout et je n'ai pas démissionné
avant la fin même quand je me suis fait
beaucoup secoué les parlers par les gens
m'en a d'ailleurs voulu mais je voudrais
lui il a voulu trop bien la maison
né parvient à la maison je suis dit
emmanuel si tu veux que la gauche
l'emportent à la présidentielle il faut
que nous soyons rassemblés et vous
fréquentez vous voyez souvent le chef de
l'état françois hollande est ce qu il a
perdu tout espoir de le ramener à mais
je ne sais pas mais à la raison jean
vignolles
à raison je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
ramener emmanuel macron à la raison
c'est à lui de prendre ses
responsabilités on va pas faire la danse
du ventre de devant lui rappaz lui
promettre je ne sais pas quoi y'a rien à
promettre aujourd'hui dans le jeu est
clair c'est que marine le pen est aux
portes du pouvoir dans ce pays et je
pense que la gauche est plus à même que
la droite de l'empêcher d'arriver au
pouvoir
quel crédit apporter vos sondages qui
donnent françois hollande battu emmanuel
comme ceux comme ceux d'hillary clinton
et de juppé la semaine dernière nous
verrons bien
oui mais vous êtes persuadé quand même
un peu comme pour fillon un sondage ne
dit jamais la vérité six mois avant une
élection est sûre ça veut bien sûr
france en ai déjà parlé évidemment je ne
sais pas qui sera élu président de la
république par an le 6 mai ou en mai
2017 est une chose dont je suis persuadé
et que je vois depuis trois-quatre jours
c'est que la semaine dernière quand j'ai
rencontré les sénateurs socialistes et
d'autre il me disait je crois bien que
c'est foutu
depuis lundi je pense que c'est jouable
merci stéphanie troisième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
michaël szames s2 public sénat
on sert michael 300 michel sardou et
guillaume bonsoir alors la question
gérard larcher vous voulez faire du
sénat le laboratoire de l'alternoce est
ce qu'il est devenu le laboratoire de
françois fillon
non je pense que c'est plus un
laboratoire c'est le cimetière des
éléphants et ce qu'elle nous sorte mais
je vais vous expliquer je pense que le
rôle premier d'un parlementaire cette cg
essaie notamment de voter le budget la
droite a fait un choix
ça voulait pas digérer ça et je n'ai pas
digéré
quand on pense au nombre de gens à
droite comme à gauche qui veulent
supprimer le sénat
quand la droite supprime le budget au
sénat que reste-t-il
et donc je crois vraiment que par
rapport à ce que dit le président gérard
larcher pour lequel gilles plus le plus
grand respect c'est instamment président
du sénat il n'y a pas de sujet mais il
disait nous voulons construire le budget
de l'alternance est là pour des raisons
politiques et politiciennes ne seront
pas amenés à voter le budget à aborder
le budget même pas comme il l'avait fait
en 2012 et 2013 au moins la première
partie rien rien du tout la droite
refuse le débat car elle sait je la
ferme ce soir elle sait que les
propositions dont nous venons de parler
s'était mis là sur la table aujourd'hui
leur servirait pas pour l'élection
présidentielle
ils sont capables de tout ça paraît si
vous l'avez nord aujourd'hui on disait
comme les enfants disent je peux pas
venir j'ai piscine
aujourd'hui ce que dit la la la droite
sénatoriale c'est moi je peux pas venir
j'ai primaire donc voilà la politique
vous dites en quelque sorte que la
primaire s'est invitée au sénat elle est
victime un petit peu de cette primaire
la primaire s'est invitée au sénat et le
sénat est victime de la primaire et de
fait la conséquence c'est qu'il n'y aura
pas de budget et je pense que ce n'est
pas bien du tout pour le sénat c'est
pour les sénateurs c'est une faute
politique qu'il croit faute grave alors
bien entendu par rapport à tout ce que
l'on voit là aujourd'hui il faut
relativiser ce mais je commence tout ça
comme le parent dance pop urines jambes
dans ce populisme dans tout ce qu'ils
montrent du doigt les parlementaires
tous ceux qui montrent du doigt le sénat
john cena ne sert à rien ça coûte cher
il ya une deuxième chambre ne pas
si j'ai pour voter le budget parce qu'on
va siéger avoir des débats des
discussions pour occuper la galerie pour
que public sénat puisse tourner c'est
l'après midi son émission 360 etc
c'est pour ça qu'ils font ça je suppose
c'est pas à la hauteur de l'événement
vraiment nous aurions aimé nous aurait
aimé nous qu'en 2011
rappelez vous lorsque nous avons pris
nous avons été majoritaires au sénat
le plf 2012 nous avons fait le plf de
l'alternance nous et aujourd'hui ils
prennent des prétextes fallacieux d un
article 40 ce n'est pas possible c'est
faux et kaino discute budget est
insincère et électoraliste mais rendait
le sincère mais baisser le nombre de
fonctionnaires de budget des
fonctionnaires augmente elle a augmenté
la tva c'est fort c'est fort possible
passé aux 39 heures mais ils ne veulent
pas le faire parce qu'ils savent très
bien qu'aujourd'hui ils sont dans leurs
primaires et il s'adresse à la droite et
la droite je pense peut se retrouver sur
ce programme de cassure sociale c'est et
alain juppé en 1995 lorsqu'il était
premier ministre parce qu'il faut se
rappeler était premier ministre en 1995
il ya 22 ans 21 ans il voulait se battre
contre la fracture sociale
là il veut assumer la cassure sociale et
françois fillon qui a toujours voulu
dire du sang et des larmes faut dire la
vérité aux français
j'ai un pays en faillite mais là
aujourd'hui ne dis pas que les comptes
sont redressés et françois fillon dit on
va leur en faire baver et notamment aux
plus vulnérables et bien ce tour sans
gloire dès ce soir de tout mettre sur la
table surtout sur la table les nounous
s'étaient pressées leur budget nous
sommes prêts et nous sommes prêts il
travaillait à participer nous en avons
parlé en commission des finances
allez-y cet après midi c'était
absolument ahurissant ce qui s'est passé
nous étions en commission des finances
pour aborder le budget des collectivités
territoriales avec deux amendements qui
était présenté par les rapporteurs de la
commission
alors que on ne va pas en débattre ça
n'a aucun sens mais aucun sens
alors parce que nous sommes des humains
c'est la voix de dieu parce que nous
sommes des du responsable nous allons
commission nous disons que nous ne
partageons pas leur leur avis d'ailleurs
la présidente de la commission des
finances l'a dit tout à l'heure
il ya beaucoup de budget qui ont été
votées en commission des finances mais
chaque fois que la droite sénatoriale
vote contre un budget elle va pas contre
parce que ce budget est trop important
il dépense trop elle vote comme parce
qu'elle jamais assez jamais assez ce
n'est pas se dire en quelle image cela
renvoie sur senna est ce que vous
estimez qu'il ya une part de
responsabilité de la part du président
du sénat ah oui bien sûr oui il ya une
part de responsabilité prévient gina moi
je pense que le président du sénat
aurait dû imposer imposé que le ce débat
se tienne et ce budget soit moins
torride à moins qu'ils le fassent mais
peut-être je vous dis ils étaient trop
occupés par leur primaire peut-être
qu'ils ont préfet prioriser la primaire
au au budget je crois que c'est
regrettable
un parlementaire qui n'a pas accès au
budget qui ne peut pas en démat voter
les recettes de l'état
voter des dépenses ne fait pas son
boulot honnêtement vous dites donc ses
responsabilités aussi également du
président du sénat la droite veut
supprimer c'est dans mon sang si
françois fillon et président de la
république vu les soutiens qu'il a au
sénat sur cette action c'est une voiture
qui s'engagent dans cette direction mais
je pense que ce serait une erreur
à droite comme à gauche et des gens qui
veulent supprimer le bicamérisme je
pense ça serait une erreur maintenant si
vous me dites qu'il faut que rien ne
bouge non on peut pas mettre un an et
demi pour voter une loi ce n'est pas
possible
moi je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
que les choses qui doivent avancer
moi je suis pour la suppression de la
dotation parlementaire de la réserve
parlementaire je le dis depuis longtemps
c'est éculés ça n'a plus aucun sens et
l'argent qui est donné à chaque sénateur
ou député pour financer des dés
je suis oui des associations moi j'en
donne pas parce que je pense que c'est
pas normal c'est du clientélisme mais
des mets y compris des investissements
dans les mairies fort ému d'être
attribué au préfet pour augmenter la
dotation aux collectivités locales
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
avoir deux lectures trois relectures
pour un texte une lecture ça suffit je
pense que la procédure accélérée de
donner à la procédure normale en fait un
aller retour et après on voit que les
conclusions ça suffit que vous avez
l'air des réseaux sociaux à l'ère des
réseaux sociaux on met un an et demi
pour voter une loi votée ce que vous
espérez que françois hollande si les
candidats prennent pour lui les mesures
que vous voulez annoncé jeu j'espère que
je sais que je sais qu'il y aura un
volet institutionnel dans tous les
candidats je suis pour le maintien du
sénat pour la diminution du nombre
oui je crois pour la diminution du
nombre de députés de sénateurs sans peut
faire des efforts pour qu'on ait plus de
moyens de contrôle
un peu comme il se passe au au sénat
américain noah une contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement des moyens d' expertise
et puis que l'on que la loi un peu un
peu plus vite et à partir de là je pense
que ça irait je ne suis pas pour un
sénat qui serait à la fois le
rassemblement comme le bundesrat
allemand
le rassemblement de tous les élus locaux
non moi je suis pour la limitation
drastique du cumul des mandats je suis
j'ai été cumulards et je suis pour un
mandat de parlementaire unique sans
aucun autre accompagnement
merci merci merci didier guillot merci à
vous de nous aujourd'hui la semaine
prochaine mais c'est gérard h et que
vous avez évoqué il ya un instant qui
sera l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir à tous et la semaine prochaine